people meet people meet KSI and they're
like expect him to be this horrible but
he's like one of the nicest people I've
ever met in my entire life and has time
for everyone but yeah his go is like
killing the world
YouTubers aren't anymore just like kids
in bedrooms making videos uh they're out
here you know
I'm gonna put this out here and I think
that KSI is the the next Rock
like
gonna be absolutely huge in in tenure
like everyone in the world will know him
[Music]
so firstly for those watching who don't
know who you are can you give us a
little introduction to yourself yes
I am Callum McGinley is my real name but
uh calyx online a YouTuber for the last
10 12 years
and make shoes now and own a production
company there's a couple of things we'll
start off right at the story so what was
your childhood like
old heard it's a good question you know
childhood wasn't the best
uh didn't have a big family around me
like mum and dad in in London but they
were separated
um didn't have the most money grew up in
a council estate in East London my mum
had to like get people to come round and
like just to give us bread milk and like
some orange juice and that was kind of
what we'd live off like beans on toast
and stuff so shout out to my mum
actually because
really like one that I grew up with her
and weren't like given the best hand but
she she definitely like made the most of
it on YouTube and online like obviously
we only show the best parts of our life
but uh I think that a lot of people they
forgot or they they guess that we've all
gone to like their most amazing schools
and we had all this money but um it was
probably exactly the opposite so yeah
when when I I'm sure we'll get into this
but um when I was younger I had leukemia
so Childhood Cancer and
um I'd been ill for like two or three
weeks and I woke up one morning I was
sleeping in my mum's bed I was age four
or five I woke up and and uh the the
pillow was I was like stuck to the
pillow and um
uh it was like I thought I checked my
hands there was like blood over them and
and then I tried to wake my mum and she
was like go back to sleep it was like 4
AM 5 a.m so I was like okay I'll go back
to sleep then and then I wake up like
six or seven let down it's actually all
red everywhere and um she turned
overlooked at me and we didn't have a
phone in the house so it didn't have
like a landline phone and so she had to
go shout like two balconies down to the
street for someone to like call an
ambulance and come free so it was like
literally didn't have anything and how
long would that battle kind of last for
it was about two years two years yeah so
like what what are your memories of that
time
I remember like yeah the bad stuff like
the in the ambulance going like oh I
don't know what's wrong with me on the
way to the hospital getting there my mum
coming back crying being like you're
going to be here for a while what does
that mean
um uh then like every two weeks you'd go
for a lumbar puncture which if you don't
know what it is it's like they shove a
huge needle in your back
um so that would be like every two weeks
and knock me out and do that
you just remember the bad stuff so it's
like yeah you get you isolation in a
room away from
um my parents for like two weeks
um but obviously Miss years one and two
at school so like key years in your in
your life and they were gone and taken
away from me so yeah that was kind of
the stuff that I do remember is there
any positive stuff that I remember
is can there be I don't know well I
suppose I was gonna say a part of the
positive thing is like homies and your
mum was because yeah it made her really
ill actually yeah yeah I think off the
back of it and the stress and everything
that went into it she she got really ill
off that yeah I remember the night says
she sleep next to me and she'd asked the
hospital if she could like literally
Camp next to the bed and uh so yeah
honestly
yeah I wouldn't have been able to
[Music]
um
shatter
so how did that period of illness impact
you in your later childhood I think I
always knew that I had to try harder
than the other kid so my mum like be
that into me
um
I think that off the back of it I don't
know I was quite skinny pale young kid
not much has changed
um but uh yeah I was always like a bit
different to the people at school and
then I think that kind of sculpted my
um my personality a little bit and I was
probably like the class clown or I try
and if I if I wasn't looking like other
people I'd try and make other people
laugh and I think that's kind of as I
say like not wanting to change much in
my life that's probably them sculpted me
for who I am today so there's been like
multiple steps in my life where it's
been like I could have literally gone in
one or two ways like
uh how he brought up or your parents are
separated bang you've gone into
different ways
um there's been some trouble with
addiction in in my family as well then
there's like you have leukemia where do
you go has been super lucky that
that through my mum through who I am
we've been able to like break out of
that entire mold and be alive and be
well and have a great thing going for me
now
what made you then start a YouTube
channel what made you get into that
world
I wasn't very academic and there's not
much at schools or there wasn't
historically that kind of catered for
people that were maybe a little bit more
creatively minded rather than
academically minded if I'd have pla
applied myself to
academics as I have done with the
creative side of my life I would have
been like I don't know I'd like to think
that I'd be at like Oxford but I just
wasn't set for that I my brain doesn't
work like that and you weren't catered
For
being creative so you I tried my best to
be in terms that I did drama
um
I didn't do arcs I couldn't draw but I I
basically tried to do as many creative
things as I could and that came across
as sport as well like football rugby
squash really good at squash because it
was like there's an art to it
and then I was like I'm really good at
Call of Duty I'm going to show the world
that I'm going to Call of Duty so I play
with my schoolmates and then again like
didn't have that much money through this
period so it's like I have a laptop for
Christmas
my dad was like yeah you can have a
laptop for Christmas because it went in
and out of contact with with him during
my childhood
um and originally it was like laptop
like a old Acer laptop that I would turn
the other way facing towards my small
20-inch TV and the laptop would record
the screen
and then I'd upload that onto onto
YouTube really good at Call of Duty
started Eclipse channel the only way I
can describe it is is like you being
framed for college Eclipse so cool
interesting stuff that happened I'd
curate it upload three times a day for
like a year or two
and then dropped out a uni and at the
end of the year I just didn't turn up to
my final exam because I was like this is
me this is my future I believe in this
so much didn't tell my mom just came
home and I was like oh yeah they're not
I'm not going back next year like
they've sent this letter and I'm not
going back it's just like crying
obviously everything that she did to get
me to that point I'd then thrown out the
window
sorry man but I believe I believe that I
really I believed in it I I knew that
this was going to be the future but by
how engrossed I was in it were you
making enough money at that point for
that to be a career or was it that much
of a gamble you just you went for anyway
yeah there was no money there was no
money whatsoever in it back then the
only money was like
Machinima contracts I think so if you if
you got yourself a Machinima contract
then you were like singing so I I like
had a couple friends that had shows on
there and I'd I'd edit together
Clips or show or bits of the show and
then try and get paid that way but when
I left uni I don't think I was earning
any money and then
a week after I left I I got contacted by
a a YouTube Network called base 79 who
are now Brave bison I think they were
bought by wrightster
and uh Rich Mansell who um is is now
still my manager co-founded after party
Studios with me works for me
um on no two ways as well he interviewed
me when they were just bringing me in to
look at to sign my channel up the Call
of Duty Channel and he was like this guy
knows so much about YouTube like offered
me a job on the spot so I started next
Monday went out of uni straight into a
YouTube job worked there for three and a
half
years
quit the Black Ops Channel started calyx
and the rest is history but when did you
really start to feel your career as a
content creator take off yeah it was it
was my first video on the calyx Channel
because I was like what shall I do what
is no one else doing and what can I how
can I be different
and I think there was like one other
person at the time that was doing public
interviews out in London and um
I think it was a Sam Pepper
and
um so I just went out and tried to do
something a bit different to him yeah my
first video was animal Impressions where
I went out what's your favorite animal
were you doing impression for me so
stupid but just wanted to carve a niche
and
and do something different and that's
when it you know I think my first video
did 110 000 views when I had no
subscribers so I was like oh right I'm
onto something here just want to ask you
what's your favorite animal animal uh
tiger can you make can you do an
impression of a tiger
can you do an impression of a horse
thank you
how many subscribers have you got now I
got four million I can't actually
believe it and every time you think
you've hit like
the top
then it just keeps going and I think um
I'm still I'm so lucky to be surrounded
by such a an amazing group of
like-minded people the sidemen Carl
Randy and all the other UK YouTubers
that are doing their own thing and
trying to push forward all the time I
knew that would be the future I didn't
know it was gonna be the future future I
didn't know that we'd be sitting here
now and you lot care about like what
what we've done with our lives and how
it's happened
there were still times when I was a
YouTuber and I was a couple years in
where I had to like borrow money from
wonga.com
and then pay it back a couple weeks
later when I you know when I got paid so
and it's pretty much only like in the
last year or two that I'm like okay cool
maybe this is like something that I can
do to generate generational wealth and
not just like like make sure that
everyone below me and my family is good
because I I wasn't given the best start
so how how can I give everyone else
below me a good start
how would you describe your content now
um
um I think I was one of the first
YouTubers to come up with like a single
idea and then go and execute in the best
way possible in the olden days in the
olden days back a couple years ago I'd
pick a thing like I'm gonna prank my
friends in a seance prank and then do it
and then
film every single part of it make sure
it's meticulously edited and a really
stunning thing to watch
is there a video that sticks out in your
head is the video you're most proud of
yeah the movember series that I filmed
last year
um basically trying to get young men to
open up about their mental health and
just talk to each other and have a
conversation when times are hard and
even when times are not hard but just
have a secure group around you that you
trust and that you can talk to about
anything
your two favorite fishermen have arrived
what's up everyone hello welcome I'm
here today with Ethan we're going to do
some fly fishing but not only are we
fishing we're gonna catch a fish gut it
and then eat it have you fished before
never
so do you feel better prepared for
lockdown oh I saw you talk about this
the other day you said that this time
around you actually uh you're doing
prepared for it yeah you're doing good I
wasn't
why not they did some research myvember
did and 50 of um boys in the UK that are
aged 15 to 25 saw those movember videos
last year
which is like nuts it's like
it's it's such a real tangible
uh set of data like people still come up
to me on the street and they go when are
you making more of these videos because
like they were great
um so I think there's the single videos
I'm super proud of but as a series that
November thing I think has changed a lot
of people's lives and uh well I like to
think so the amount of messages and the
engagement that I got off at the back of
it was crazy so really glad that I did
those videos but it's so weird that the
audience that like they they see us as
these like
amazing god-like creatures that don't
have anything going on when you talk
about like oh yeah I was on my own for
three months in lockdown they're like ah
no way
so I think we just need to bear that in
mind a little bit more that they they
just see and believe and and consume us
in our best possible State when it's not
always like that
what's the point for you during this
whole Creator Journey that's been the
hardest point for you mentally
it's really tough to pick out a single
moment in time there's been times where
I've been like super low
um and you know but but they wouldn't be
down to like
what I do maybe it's just a bit of
everything or it's personal life that
then seeps into
but the actual
journey I think is always hard
and you just need to keep overcoming it
and that's life like lifestyle
there's no single point it's just that
you go through these small battles maybe
every day every week or every month or
you'll be good for a couple months and
then something will knock you off your
um your ledge your pedestal whatever and
then you just kind of have to it's how
you get up from that so I think that
YouTube in itself is like an unrelenting
Beast that that is you'll make an
amazing video and you'll see some you'll
see some creators make amazing videos
and then
they won't upload for like months
afterwards because like they've put all
their work and effort into this one
video and then they're like oh I have to
go and do that again
and again and again and again until you
just stop so I think it's that like
the never-ending
you know it just keeps going I think
that that's the hardest bit has that
ever brought you to the point of burnout
oh I've been out like five times now
yeah because I used to throw my all into
each video and and and and then I'd sit
there afterwards and you'd get that
dopamine hit straight away of like oh
it's on a million views in 12 hours 2
million three million and then uh you're
like to do this again yeah and again
keep going you know as long as you've
got good people around you to talk to
you and you do some fun stuff on the
side and look after yourself go to
therapy
um then you're good you're fine
what's been the happiest moment in that
Creator Journey you've had
um probably the first release of no two
ways
um I started sneaker brand about two
years ago and
that first release was like kind of
everything that I'd worked for and
everything that I've learned
to then put 750 pairs of shoes on sale
at 6 pm
on the 15th of August
and then them sell out in 63 seconds
but there's a clip of the whole thing
happening and I just burst out crying
straight away I don't know why
because I it was almost like I was I
wasn't sad I was just like overwhelmed
by like my whole I didn't know that my
path was going to leave me here but my
whole path led me to this point where
I started a brand and people cared so
much that it sold out 60 Seconds
like this is not YouTube Merch this is
another level entirely how did this come
about yeah well it's interesting you say
that it's not YouTube merch because
obviously
we did a we did a piece of research and
that was what like people said they were
like this is so different which means so
much because that's what we tried to do
from the beginning
I had a passion for sneakers for years
and years and years I wouldn't say like
I'm an early early sneaker head going
back back but say I'm a new generational
Sneakerhead and so I was collecting
buying pieces trying to sell them so on
so on and I was like wait hold on a
second like why has no one done this
before like actually made their own the
majority of the time a big celebrity or
an influencer or someone will
want to do say sneakers or makeup and
they'll go to a brand and they'll
co-produce it with them I was like
I
I
knew that that was the only way in for
me at the beginning so I I did that I
hit up two Brands um one of them came
around my house looked in my collection
I was like yeah yeah come down to the
factory next week
um never got in contact with me again
and didn't reply to any of my emails it
was a warm intro as well as well it was
it was a friend of a friend
and they never got back to me so I was
like you know what you
sorry I know you're probably gonna I
don't mean it like that but like as in
but you're probably a really nice guy
but
uh
but like I'm gonna go do this myself
and so I did and I kept like throwing it
out into the world I'd be on sheets like
this I'd be like does anyone know I want
to start shoes does anyone know anyone
met a couple people and then met Rocky
uh Rockwell princely
the most humble talented guy I've ever
met in any of any of my industries that
I've worked in
he knows absolutely everything about
trainers I knew he was the guy after 15
minutes of me and him and from there
yeah just started I guess the why is
because
um
I had an interest in sneakers and
because no one else had done it and I
love taking risks and
um throwing my own money into projects
that have probably no probability of
getting it back ever or it's a huge risk
that's what Richard likes to say my
manager or Mentor likes to say is just
like you love taking a risk but they
just keep paying off so yeah
how do you even start designing a shoe
yeah
um well I wanted to make something
completely from scratch so
obviously the option was there to just
buy a shoe from the pre-made shoe and
put a logo on the side of it and I think
that's what maybe 90 of other people
would have done because it's really hard
I brought some I'm allowed to yeah yeah
I brought some with me
um
so I've got like a a very early sample
this was the first shoe that we released
exuberance and then here's like a
earliest sample they're supposed to be
the same shoe or this is like a
this is the real one and this is
probably
thirds third or fourth sample that we
got through
and absolutely everything on here is is
designed by us but it was kind of about
the hardest thing to do for us at the
beginning was the the outsole because
it's um it's around two three four
thousand dollars per size to open a mold
for an outsole so immediately at the
beginning you're going to be chucking in
50 Grand just for one part of the shoe
and then yeah pretty much everything we
we did months of trend research we did
um looked at who our competitors might
be what you know fashion is designed
maybe a year or two ahead
so we went to kind of conferences events
had a look at what materials were coming
in what colors and palettes and we spent
basically eight months straight barely
uploaded any YouTube videos
just kind of working out what it's going
to look like and this is where we got to
very early on
um you'll see that they are you know a
little bit similar but we've got
different uh midsole outsole and then
we've taken some Stars off but the
design is kind of there the material is
not and the colors are slightly
different and there's been some upgrades
to like the tongue and logos and so on
but this looks very generic I think with
the with the outsole
um
and I think we want it to be quite
different and uh
Rocky uh you know I can't take much
credit I can take credit for some of the
decisions along the way but
um and we worked on this shoe together
but it's his you know ideation and his
know-how that went into this and I think
that we've got a silhouette now that is
quite recognizable if you see on this
street even with like the orange pull
tabs which are on the majority of our
shoes or just this chunky
um midsole outsole kind of thing here
that that yeah I think is is so
different to everyone else there's so
much so now that like h m and other
people are copying it but that's finally
happening which is sick thank you so
much
but I think this one as well looked like
a little bit childish a little bit
rounded
um every single decision basically we
sat there for hours and hours going
right is it a gummy Soul does it fade
um what's the quality of this it
what leather should we use should it be
uh something that is vegan or should it
be something that's um nubuck or
something else and
and the price difference in that and how
much should the shoe cost so in the end
the shoe actually this is a really
expensive shoe that should probably
should be on sale for like two three
four hundred pounds from any other brand
but we I wanted to sell it for 90
um which basically meant that we made no
money on the first one
um
but I just I just wanted to make the
best possible product
I think many people have seen this as
well it's amazing to see something
exclusive no it even says on the bottom
yeah what's fascinating is just it's
seeing the progression like you can see
where the creative decisions have been
made together and then you know then
we've moved on to kind of where we are
now this is the first time that these
have ever been shown on camera oh so I
don't know when this is coming out
um but these are these are going to be
very soon I don't know if they'll be
next but I just thought I'd wear
something special today yeah
get the exclusive
um so like looking at your YouTube
channel over the past few years is it
fair to say that the budget of your
videos has got higher in the last last
year in particular maybe yeah I started
after party Studio as as a thing to
enable me to make higher quality content
but then it slowly started to slip away
from me in terms of like
they started doing like amazing stuff
KSI can't lose Sony pictures
um the documentary about ksi's first
fight and leading up to the Logan Paul
one if you haven't watched yet by the
way it's it's actually amazing but it's
made now it's made by us directed by
Rubber Duck
um
and then we've worked with like Netflix
and so many other companies now
so yeah it was there to kind of make my
content get better but now it's often
it's doing its own thing and
um I'm still there every day no two ways
after partying calyx are all in the same
office now
um in East London
um but I'd say in the last year
I actually don't like high quality
videos I don't like shooting stuff like
this anymore I don't like it because I
think it takes away the audience feel a
little bit alienated by it I think they
want to see a GoPro that's in 1080P
that's zoomed in four times
yeah I don't want to see this
um but this has a time and a place like
my my movember videos or I've seen like
filmed like this
but I try and stay away from it now
actually I don't know I think it I think
it's gone full circle take me back to
filming with my laptop camera
they'll see that in the next video then
let's do it but okay like but then when
you're looking around now on YouTube who
inspires you
um
I think the beautiful thing about our
friend group is that everyone's doing
their own thing so I'm actually inspired
by all of those guys
I actually saw a care there's a clip of
JJ the other day
um someone sent it to me yesterday him
saying that he's the richest at the
moment but I'm going to be the richest
in the future but isn't it amazing that
you can have that conversation it's not
about being obviously that stems from
like doing cool [ __ ]
and I think that we're all doing it so
I'm inspired by all of them and I hope
that I Inspire some of them as well but
if I have to pick someone like David
dobrik obviously like revolutionize
vlogging
um and Mr Beast is is just Mr Beast
congrats on 100 million
um
so there's some of the things that he's
done within his business and how he runs
his YouTube channel I've taken
um but yeah hopefully you know I've
helped Inspire some other younger
creators as well in the same way
what do you think is the future of
content
I think it's I think tick tock's ruining
people's minds but I do love it but like
if we're being serious like people's
attention spans are already quite bad
going from like TV and film to YouTube
and now we've got stuff that you can get
a hit of dopamine every five seconds you
can literally squirrel
yeah wow yeah you feel it that's funny
you laugh you send it to a friend bang
next one
and you can just keep doing that it's
just like
casino slot machine every time you flick
your your it's the slot machine you're
pulling it you've just got unlimited
coins but you'd actually don't know that
the coins that you're giving away are
your own mind your mental health you
compare and compare comparing yourself
to other people
don't realize what this is doing now and
and
unfortunately as a Creator you you need
to take this in mind because this is the
stuff that what is working
things will come back around but I think
at the moment
kind of wish Tick Tock was banned
you grew up probably watching television
and watching TV four channels uh yeah
four channels I'm interested to know
like as a YouTuber who's 30. how do you
not View television
look they're TV's finally like getting
some YouTubers on board in certain
places talent shows or whatever uh I was
in LA like two days ago and I saw um
Liza koshy I think that's her name Koshi
uh up on a billboard with like oh who
was it it was like
two Mega celebrities and then her and
she's super famous in the US I'm not
going to take that away from her but
five years ago you wouldn't have seen
that yeah no way that would have been
another famous person
so I think TV is finally embracing us
but I there's they're nowhere near where
they should be they should we should be
on the TV every day but guess what
uh the KSI did uh ask me anything on
Reddit yesterday and I read through it
and one of the things like will we ever
see you on TV and he went
because I we are the TV you took too
long you didn't believe in us and now
we're gone and like your watch time is
just gonna go down down and down down
unless you come up with clever ways to
embrace what what the kids want to watch
you talked about having a good group of
people around you and like you've come
up with and built the you like the side
man and calfresi and all these people
what's it been like growing your Brands
together
I think the um
I like in
our our relationship is I
it's like it's almost the same as uni
and like you go to UNI study subject and
those people that you're with like your
your lives have led here and you have
common interest
but then on YouTube I think it's even
just beyond that as well I think it's
like you've all gone through this time
where you had to do
ideation editing promotion marketing how
do you make money what's next
so we're all so like-minded
because I think that we've actually also
not only just because we're doing the
same stuff over the last 10 years but
we've also been sculpted by the business
um
so it's like having another you know
nine brains that are exactly the same
you think the same way but everyone has
their own intricacies or their their
specialisms so it's been it's almost
like perfect I wouldn't I wouldn't have
wanted it any other way
people meet people meet KSI and they
like expect him to be this horrible but
he's like one of the nicest people I've
ever met in my entire life and has time
for everyone but yeah his go is like
killing the world
I I got uh Addison Lee on the way here
right and I drove past the sidemen on a
billboard at Old Street
um defy expectations a brand deal on the
side I was like wow and that's just
happening more and more you've got
Bazinga on a board you've got KSI on a
bus because it's Capital you've
YouTube is on anymore just like kids in
bedrooms making videos uh they're out
here you know
I'm gonna put this out here and I think
that KSI is the the next Rock
like
gonna be absolutely huge in in 10 years
like everyone in the world will know him
like when you look at that Journey from
where you were with no money
to where you are now with this entire
business underneath you
how does that make you feel yeah there
was actually it's really interesting
that you asked that question there was a
moment
the other day when the office was pretty
full
and I was like every single person in
here
works for companies that were my
brainchild
and I was like yeah I can't take credit
for kind of some of the steps that have
taken along the way especially in after
party Studios because it it went off and
became its own Beast it's an incredible
production company on its own
and you know what it's not just like
a group of people that yeah all work for
for me or all the ideas that I've
created but
are a group of people that are all so
nice I know this is kind of slightly
like left field of what your question
was but
I think I'm so lucky
to have such an amazing group of people
around me and definitely wouldn't be at
the heights I am now without them
so there's also like the pride in that
like just having such a solid group of
people because the way I the way our
lights are higher generally is like are
you good at what you do yes cool
and some people might stop there the
next level is like
are you a nice person and I think we put
a lot into that that'd be really nice
um
like care and and I'll be able to trust
you and stuff like that
is number two and then number three is
like are they smarter than me
so I drop your ego to the side is this
person actually gonna be able to teach
you something and and Propel your career
calm is there anything else you want to
talk about is there anything else you
think we've missed that you would like
to cover
I think you just got my whole life in
like 45 minutes
no I'm good
[Music]
yeah probably footballers boxers
um I get a lot of rappers in my DMs I do
want a DM from Jack Hardo but I haven't
had that yet so
yeah Jack if you're watching this I will
see you soon